thank you
foreign
oh
hello
everyone
what's goody
hello
welcome
everyone welcome to the September 100
joke contest
yeah yeah
do y'all like how the music dropped when
I said welcome to the contest yeah yeah
shouty
we out here happy Sunday out there thank
you all for hanging out with us today
Phyllis from Philadelphia is here good
to see you we have Alberto
CGM sounds we have
Sandy Bernstein one of our finalists we
have Cynthia and Jordan
blondeago18 good to see y'all whether
you're watching us on our YouTube
channel
or our Facebook group
welcome aboard
welcome one and all welcome to the show
here we do this every single month
I am your host
comedian Joel Byers I'm the host of hot
breath podcast
and every single month here
we do this 100 joke contest where people
compete we get a secret theme
and then people get two weeks to write a
new 90 second set based on that theme
and then the winner
gets a hundred bucks and an interview on
the world famous hot breath podcast so
as we come in here today we say what is
Goodie my friends
hope you're all having a good Sunday out
there we're about to jump right into
this this is how it's gonna go down my
friends if this is your first time
tuning in here
and if it is your first time tuning in
go ahead and subscribe to our YouTube
channel we have over 400 interviews with
the top comics in the game so go ahead
and subscribe to the YouTube channel as
we're coming in here
and uh let us know where you're tuning
in from here looks like we have some
peeps
tuning in here
Phyllis from Philadelphia as we said Les
Claypool hello from Atlanta we got ATL
in the building
good to see you day dashayas as well
hola hola
uh buenos dias
way way day
away
uh Jerry Kroll from Phoenix oh this is
gonna be good he said this is gonna be
fun to watch Good Luck to Sandy Sandra
and Bob
this is gonna be fun y'all cause how
it's gonna work is we have our three
finalists today my wife and I watch all
the submissions together isn't that
sweet
and then Oh I thought I had a sound
effect there but
um
yay there it is
so my wife and I watch all the
submissions and then we pick the top
three finalists and you watching today
are a part of something special because
we're going to play the three final sets
and then you are gonna vote for who wins
the September we're on October but this
is the September contest
we're gonna vote see who wins 100 bucks
and the interview on the podcast which
we're gonna do live on this live stream
and at the end of this live stream I'm
going to announce the October theme
so you're definitely going to want to
hang out for that
yes ooh indeed
so as people are coming in here
we're gonna run down the rules and then
we're gonna jump right into it my
friends because I know it's Sunday I
know y'all took your valuable time to
hang out with us today for the next hour
and I appreciate that so much what this
contest started at during the pandemic
let's start as a way for
people to just hold each other
accountable to write more consistently
during the pandemic when motivation was
low
and now it's turned into a global joke
writing contest so if it's something
you're interested in if you just want to
learn more about joke writing or you'd
like to compete on here and maybe win
100 bucks and an interview on the
podcast
you can join our comedy writing master
class at hot breathmedia.com and that is
where you'll get access to the private
Facebook group where we do this contest
every single month
yes hot breathmedia.com
is where all the goodies are in the
hoodies
um I will link that in the chat for
y'all just in case it's something you
maybe want to join in on us for next
month
and I will pin that to the top there
oh it looks I'm looks like I'm getting
roasted in here a little bit Zach
Matthews good to see you Bob Kirk in the
building
Evelyn
Adrian Adrian said I look like Angus
Young
oh I look young oh thank you Adrian
thank you
we have Carla in here I know you were
roasting me but I pivoted that into a
fun
compliment instead
Sherlock gnomes says it's Akuma very
nice
Sandra Doss traveling in Virginia my
Wi-Fi is not great oh
in Virginia good to see you Sandra
Alvaro from Montreal Carla's in
Phoenixville PA
Cynthia we got Detroit
Jonestown PA oh we got a lot of PA in
here Westminster PA's Jordan
Zach Matthews is in Philly as well
goodness gracious
Lynn Biden good to see you Lynn
Pittsburgh
awesome
reporting from Panama oh Chino
williams123 good to see you yo we are
deep in here and listen it's a live
stream we're gonna get we're about to
get to the contest we just want to make
sure that everyone who wants to
experience the contest live and vote
gets a chance to get in here and we've
been doing this during the pandemic I
did a live stream every day for over 400
Days
and what I learned is you know it takes
people some time to get in and involved
so I appreciate all of you all for
hanging out especially if this is your
first time tuning in on this YouTube
channel we do two live streams a week we
do weekly podcasts on here and so much
more yes not podcasts
podcasts you heard right and the audio
version is available on Spotify and
apple and wherever else you listen to
your podcasts as well
but without further Ado good to see you
Jack Allen Jack Allens has all the best
guys very nice
guys and gals geez Jack you're gonna get
me canceled in here just saying guys
nah these are jokes
but here's how it's gonna run down my
friends here are your finalists we have
hot breath ogs Sandy Bernstein Sandra
Doss and Bob Kirk
we have them in the finals this week
this month excuse me
but without further Ado my friends
no agent said I love your work on Dirty
Deeds Done Dirt Cheap you're welcome
I don't get that reference you must be
very much so older than me Adrian I'm
too young to get that reference if you
couldn't tell by my beautiful face
that is going on
some sleep you know had a gig at a
Western Carolina University last night
it was such a blast it was family night
I love performing in front of families
because
kids laugh at different things than the
parents and the kids were digging it
some of y'all that know me know I'm on a
hashtag bring back the dab movement
the kids were bad about it okay and
that's where change starts with the
children and I'm changing not by
educating
but by advocating so keep a lookout for
hashtag bring back the dab
and without further Ado my friends
Carla says go Sandra dos oh boy all
right peeps so we got we got a tight
competition today these are all OG's in
the hot breath versus what we call us
here the hot breath of Earth so welcome
aboard everyone um Maria
said go Sandra as well
oh
so this is gonna be good so here's how
we're gonna do it my friends
we're gonna play each set
and then you will vote at three watch
all the sets you will vote for who you
want to hear live on the show today
they're gonna come on the show live and
get interviewed and they're gonna win a
hundred bucks
so the order will be
let me see if I can get a drum roll here
stop the music
Let's see we can get a drum roll
foreign
try it again
there we go
so
the order will be
Sandy Bernstein
Sandra dos
and Bob Kirk that will be the running
order my friends so do prepare
yourselves as we do go into this just
give you a little insight on how my wife
and I watch these to pick the finalists
the theme this month is
School
so the theme these people wrote on was
school and what you do with that prompt
it's whatever you want it to be you can
use school and literally write about
school or you can use schools just
inspiration to create something else
but the whole goal is to inspire people
to write every single month and get paid
to do it with a hundred bucks so man a
lot of Team Sandra in the building
a lot of Team Sandra well we'll see when
the sets come out who is the winner but
as you're watching these sets do keep in
mind a few things so the theme is School
so as you're watching it keep in mind
how they use the theme of school
and keep in mind how funny is the set
it's kind of a two-parter way you want
to watch these one how strictly funny is
it how many laughs are in the set how
quickly are they getting to a laugh do
they close with a laugh are there
consistent laughs throughout and the
theme of school how did they use the
theme of school how creative were they
with it how personalized was their set
based around the theme of school and
those are just a few things to kind of
keep in mind as you're watching these
sets today to really take this seriously
I mean 100 bucks I mean listen
for my wife in the other room to hear me
you know giving away a hundred bucks you
know she's like oh is that Sallie Mae on
the computer is that what it is I was
like no I'm not paying back paying back
Sallie Mae what
student debts over a trillion dollars
she can't catch us all
which I did that joke at a college last
night on family night the parents were
thrilled to hear that one for sure
hmm
but anyway ooh Lin's here for Bob Lynn
says go Bob go very nice team note
neutral I don't know nobody says
Alvarado
nombres
[Music]
uh Chino go Sandra go vamos Sandra vamos
but as we get into it my friends
just keep those voting things in mind
we're gonna have a good time today are
y'all ready to rock here y'all ready to
rock here let's get it going here baby
[Music]
that was a lot louder than I intended it
to be
uh go Android tech asked best books for
learning comedy
um I have a whole I have a whole um if
you search
hot breath comedy books I made a video
about my favorite comedy books
um but today is the contest
so
um
um I did create a video about my
favorite books you can find on YouTube
my friend or feel free to DM me on
Instagram if you have more specific
questions at Joel byerscomedy
but in the meantime in between time my
friends I'm feeling good about this this
this this this one's got some juice to
it and I know y'all I know y'all are
feeling it too so I appreciate you all
for hanging out here and having fun with
us and without further ado
looks like we got peeps in here saying
yes we are ready to rock so the first up
we're going to have Sandy Bernstein
remember how funny is the set and also
how cleverly and creatively did they use
the theme of school
and something we um we really uh teach
in our comedy writing master class is
how to personalize your material you
want to write material that only you
could do that's the whole goal on Comedy
writing create material that no one can
steal and that's uniquely you and that's
how you find your comedic voice and
that's what students of that and
contestants in this contest are working
on every single month and you're going
to get to see a piece of that today
so
as we do here
let me see if I can find the sound
effect I'm so sorry I just gotta
I got a new like sound effect thing
and then I'm realizing I didn't set it
up
for today and you know what that's fine
um
because we drove back early from North
Carolina to do this anyway so the fact
that we're just here
and we get to meet each other is what I
love the most so with that being said
[Music]
[Applause]
first contestant up
the one the only
the Sandy Bernstein
enjoy
oh that is Sandra there's Sandy
my bad y'all
let's try that again
[Music]
[Applause]
Sandy Bernstein
I work for a university but I'm not a
women's studies Professor I'm a doctor
a spin doctor
I'm in the public relations office
big changes coming our way
meta formerly Facebook has been pushing
virtual reality as a teaching tool my
college is bought into it and is
launching a pilot program where
instruction will be delivered using VR
headsets
before you know at the whole university
will go virtual
I hated the Matrix now I gotta be in The
Matrix
oh and those big VR headsets not a good
look for me
I don't even look good in hats
now I have to worry if these genes make
my avatar look fat oh and my colleagues
I can see it now brown knows Betty
crawling up the boss's butt taking ass
kissing to a whole nother level
sure they'll be able to see me roll my
eyes and flip them off under the table
and they'll know when I fall asleep
because I'll be rendered unconscious
my husband wants me to stay positive he
said you won't have to worry about age
spots on your avatar and you could get a
boob job and a tummy tuck I'm like uh
well based on your performance last
night your avatar could use some
enhancements
oh
yeah give it up for Sandy
Sandy Bernstein a previous winner of
this contest multi-time
winner but we're kicking off with a bang
there
with Sandy Bernstein what did y'all
think of Sandy there
oh it's Akuma given the laughing crying
Emoji love on lockdown said hilarious
Dino liked
uh do these jeans make my avatar look
fat yeah that is hilarious
Julian Applause Les Claypool yeah
Les Claypool liked it
Jerry loved the Avatar joke age spots on
your avatar Evelyn liked yeah yeah yeah
a lot of good ones
a lot of love coming in a lot of a lot
of Applause here
as well
nice set says Bob look at that friendly
competition huh
one of the contestants Bob said nice set
love on lockdown like the Matrix joke
Jones says great job Sandy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah land fun and funny
Sandy oh
I love all the positivity in here that's
what we're all about here
being positive and supportive
El Gordo Mamon
good morning buenos dias mi amigo aqui
El Tiempo a Las
Ro
um foreign
um anyway it's Akuma said wow she kept
punching
yeah so a lot Phyllis said fabulous yeah
yeah a lot of people like your um Avatar
jokes as well there Sandy that was great
great job all around that's why we
started with Sanders we knew we're gonna
We're Gonna Come Out Swinging so
that is our first one
but we have two more dos mas
esta Domingo
so uh I don't know why I've been
speaking Spanish this morning I guess
I've been trying to practice I want to
start doing stand-up in Spanish and
um it all starts with doing Spanglish on
a live stream
so
oh and look at that
Sandy said thanks everyone yeah
you're very welcome there Sandy great
set and now
we have two more my friends so don't get
it twisted keep note of what you like
about each contestant so when we do get
to the voting
you do have an understanding of like
right I like this part but maybe this
person did this aspect better so just
keep uh
keep it
keep uh keep keeping it
man I love all the comments coming in
too this is fun all right
yeah I would love to do your all Spanish
show for sure
foreign
anyway
so we have two more my friends as I look
like I look like I'm an immigration
officer trying to speak Spanglish to fit
in and then
um Deport someone but I swear I'm an
ally I'm one of the good ones I swear
but anyway
let's get into the next contestant who
is
Sandra Doss my friend so you're ready
for Sandra dos
where'd it go
let's get ready
[Applause]
prepare yourselves for the comedy
of Sandra
dos
I have great memories of my school days
I went to a girls catholic school and my
favorite thing was recess because that
meant dodgeball
I love dodgeball A lot of people didn't
think it was very ladylike but I loved
it and also the nuns encouraged it hey
it would get us in the mindset of
dodging All Balls onto marriage
also I love school supplies I was the
kid that would get high smelling erasers
those Hello Kitty erasers smelled like
dulce de leche can you blame me
later on in high school my mom asked me
if I wanted to be a nurse like her and I
said well it sounds fun so if I don't
have to go to school for it sure
she was like honey the only nurses that
don't need any training are nurse sharks
and even those swim in a school hi
Veronica I ended up going to law school
and that made my parents happy
but then I decided to be a comedian they
didn't like that too much
my mom whose arthritis had made her
fingers turn into air quotation marks
said to me
are you telling me that this is a
stand-up comedy [__] is a career
Amigos
[Applause]
how fun
oh yeah Carla said that's a great one
yeah we got a lot of laughs coming in
Les said hahaha nice
very nice Cynthia go Sandra ukala Carla
Klein dise muy bueno
SI claro
good set dodgeball joke was awesome says
love on lockdown
dodging All Balls Evelyn liked the
dodging All Balls one
uh one of her husband is in the room to
hear that Evelyn is such a fan of that
uh Adrian like the air quote joke
Carla like the Hello Kitty smell joke
yeah yeah that's what I love I love
Sandra being a parent and a lawyer I
just love that's what I love about this
contest is just picturing
people who are adults
sequestered into a room recording a set
for this silliness that we do it's like
not now kids I'm doing my comedy contest
they're like but we're hungry
I just love that she's a lawyer and
she's like but I get high on markers
that's fun hmm
Dino like disappointing parents while
thrilling audiences yeah yeah yeah
buenissimo oh I haven't heard that one
before is that a word
Dave deshais
buenisimo I like that
Jerry said nice tight comedy set it felt
like I was in a club wow Maria dice
foreign
like the DodgeBall joke Phyllis like the
arthritic air quotes
I like that
look I'm learning Spanish that's what
this live stream is going to turn into
it's just me learning Spanish
hmm
she went to law school to make fun of
her life to make her life fun and
funnier love the air quote said Cynthia
yeah yeah yeah
a lot of good comments coming in here I
love the love pouring in and alas my
friends
we have one more before we do our live
voting here and this is so exciting
we're doing our live voting and we're
bringing the winner live on the show
today and we're announcing next month's
contest
so if you do want to compete in next
month's contest I did put a link to our
comedy writing master class in the live
chat of our YouTube channel where you
can join the class and get automatic
submission into this contest next month
but until then
this cat has won several times
and he's back
with the finals again
oh Alvaro said jolissimo oh I love that
it's Akuma like the dodgeballs until
marriage
Sandy said as a lawyer she gets to swim
with the sharks yeah
Jordan
Applause I love it
all right my friends we have one more
before our voting so put your put your
comedy caps on remember the previous two
sets and now
experience
the final contestant
of the September 100 joke contest
here we go
let's get her ready to rumble
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
your third and final finalist of the
joke contest all the way from Toronto
Canada
it is Bob Kirk
I'm Kirk school oh I was held back so
many times in school I had a fuller
beard the most of the teachers
and those were just the women and I was
the only one in grade four to be able to
drive
oh my favorite part of school was fire
drill my favorite clothes was detention
because you knew if there were any girls
in that class but they would be naughty
oh yeah Yeah my two favorite words class
dismissed oh I went to school when they
allowed corporal punishment so at least
you knew where you stood until they
knocked you off your feet and you were
down for the count our high school was
called the Dropout Factory to get out of
class you needed a note or a toe tag oh
great for geography class Earl sat in
front of me and the teacher asked Earl
to name the two rivers on the map
I helped Earl out I said the Nile Earl
the Nile moose the teacher laughed the
class laughed the comic was born even
today I stay in touch with some of the
kids I went to school with you know
there's nothing like having prison pen
pals School
and so am I yeah
yeah my favorite teacher was Mr Nelson
the shop teacher yeah yeah I saw him at
the reunion I ran up to Mr Nelson Mr
Nelson oh you taught me well look I
still have all my fingers
whoa keep it going
Bob Kirk my friends your final finalist
of the hundred dollar joke contest
oh Alvaro said I love his energy Adrian
said great energy Les Claypool very
animated loved the detention woman joke
yeah for sure
it's Akuma throwing out some LOLs Julian
Applause Carla very animated
they like you Bob
Jerry said what an onslaught of jokes
the Dropout Factory the toe tag the
prison pen pals I know I caught the toe
tag joke this time that's what's so
funny about watching these multiple
times
is you'll catch different jokes at
different times I don't think I caught
the toe tag one until we watched it this
time which is hilarious
uh Evelyn said better beard than the
teachers yeah
Jones had so many great punches Sandy
wow so many punch lines note or toe tag
nasty girl detention great energy
yeah for shizzle
so funny that Roberto says Lynn que
Bueno
knew they were naughty as my favorite
Jack Allen a previous winner as well
Jack Allen in the building good to see
you buddy
Dino said last per minute on fire great
going Bob I loved the toe tag and you
trolling naughty girls
she claddle
she gladly
hello Kristin as well
class dismissed fire drills lots of
laughs says Phyllis yeah yeah
and now my friends
I have just posted
in
the live stream I just posted our voting
poll the Voting is now on my friends
so pick your favorite
only vote for one
my friends only vote for one here
it's between
Sandy Bernstein Sandra dos and Bob Kirk
now it's a lot at stake here the winner
will get to come on the show live today
for an interview that'll be on our
podcast and they win a hundred bucks so
you're going to want to hang around and
I'm also going to be announcing the
theme for October's contest as well so a
lot of exciting stuff here to go in just
the final few minutes of this live
stream so I do appreciate y'all
hanging out showing so much love and
positivity that's what this channel is
all about
and if you're about that as well please
do subscribe and if you're not
necessarily A comedy writer but know
someone who wants to be or aspires to be
send our Channel their way let them know
we got a bunch of Comedy interviews to
help people level up their comedy game
and just a fun Community to tap into
we do two live streams a week on this
YouTube channel and our Facebook group
we do a daily joke writing contest
called the write 10 Club so
just a lot going on here we appreciate
y'all being a part of it
and as the Voting is coming in my
friends
I've wrestling around out there
we have some yard work to do today
this is exciting
all right
oh thank you Evelyn said best Channel
with the best resources
thank you Julian said great job all
around yeah yeah yeah yeah
a grade A Grade A Grade agreed
to where we're at in the voting so far
we have Bob
in first place Sandra in second and
Sandy in third but I'll tell you
anyone who submits to this contest is a
winner I don't think people realize
how much
work it takes to just create a 90 second
set and that's why this contest exists
to give people accountability to give
people motivation and to give people the
tools to write jokes consistently and
this contest is not only about writing
but it's also about performing and
recording and sharing the sets so it's
like there's a lot of work that goes
into this so anyone that's submitted
hats off to you my wife and I love
watching them
and um for the finalists everyone's a
winner you know if you made it this far
you know everyone's a winner but
there could only be one Highlander
they're calling me one lolander lol
Ander
I don't know
but in the final minute here before we
finalize the voting Sandra Doss is
making a
making them
yes Queen
yes yes yes so let me uh let me bring a
timer up let's do a countdown here
let's do
how about a one minute countdown
let's do a one minute countdown
boom
so in the next 60 Seconds
uh we will be announcing the winner and
Jerry asked was the B video yesterday
from my garden
um I posted a video on my um Instagram
which you guys can check out
uh at Joel Byers comedy I post a video
of a b no that was actually the video I
posted was actually from
um the guard Center we went to the
Garden Center yesterday and that's why
we're doing yard work today because we
have a lot of plant to do
um but we do have bees we do try to
plant things that are native and also
pollinator friendly you know to really
do our part
uh but thanks for asking Jerry
hot breath Comedy Club asked it's Akuma
yes
we're gonna get there for sure don't
worry we got a lot of things cooking but
it's all one bite at a time and now
I thought I had a bell sound effect
don't have a bell sound effect
oh wasn't it
there it is
so now
who is the winner holy comedy
oh it was close oh my gosh it was close
but
the man the myth the hot breath OG Bob
Kirk snuck away with it
great job Bob Kirk congratulations Bob
let's give Bob a round of applause
[Music]
yeah Bob a round of applause and we're
about to bring him live on the show as
well so Bob
what I did for you buddy is in that
group chat with all the finalists I went
ahead and put
your uh I put the interview link
to where you can join me live on the air
if you guys want to compete in next
month's contest just go to
hopbreathmedia.com and join our comedy
writing Master Class
and um that is pinned to the top of the
live chat for those of you interested
there or if you have any questions feel
free to hit me up you can um send me a
message directly on my website
joelbyerscomedy.com or
um send me a DM on social media or
whatnot you know I'm happy to answer any
questions
but um it's Okuma said wow y'all we're
all amazing I'm inspired
nice job everyone congrats Bob says love
on lockdown yeah yeah a lot of love
that was a close one for sure
oh and alvado
Alvaro asked how did you find the master
class to those who did it yes is there
anyone in the live stream
um that has
um done the master class because I would
I would like to do here as well I mean
if
I created the master class to be like my
12 years of Comedy condensed
into a single class
so I would be interested the feedback
I've gotten personally has been positive
but maybe maybe he peeps in the live
streams
oh
be interesting to hear great question
there all about oh
and I love the congrats going all around
I love the positivity and the support of
this that's what we're all about here
Mike my friends thank you all for
hanging out
and we're about to bring Bob live on the
air
and then we're gonna announce
our uh October theme as well at the end
of our interview with Bob so it's very
nice very exciting
what we're gonna do here my friends
as we're getting Bob in here he's a
little older so he has to get his text
set up
but what I'm gonna do
let me just get
Bob regular Rumble here
awesome
I'm gonna go ahead and record this is
gonna be on tomorrow's podcast I'm gonna
go ahead and record the intro
and where's Bob
here we go I'm recording the podcast
intro live on the air
what's goody hot breadthiverse welcome
back to Hot Breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros today's
episode is our 100 joke contest for
September every single month we do a
joke contest where winner gets a hundred
bucks any interview on this podcast so
if you're interested in joining that
next month head on over to our
hopbreathmedia.com check out our comedy
writing master class that is linked in
the description of this episode I don't
like that intro I don't like that intro
we're not going to use it
we're just gonna wait for Bob to get
here I didn't really like that
I've done it before
oh we got I like the praise coming in
let's get to the praise instead Jack
Allen said I've done the master class
really helpful a lot of different
writing techniques as well
thank you Jack glad you found it helpful
my friend and it looks like Jerry crawl
here
master class is extremely well put
together and gets you riding stage ready
comedy fast and gives you the tools to
be consistent
wow thank you Jerry hey it's working
I like it
and Alberto said 90 seconds looks hard
to be honest yeah it's no joke
um yeah yeah I like the 90 seconds
because it forces you to get to the
jokes quicker it really helps not only
with writing but also editing
um yeah and it's writing the set is
difficult recording the set is difficult
in the Facebook group people share like
screenshots of them doing like 20 takes
of a single 90 second set like there's a
lot of work that goes into it but the
payoff is
I mean at the very least you get a brand
new 90 second set that you can do on
stage at the most least you get that set
plus 100 bucks plus an interview on the
podcast so
without further Ado speaking of
the interview on the podcast ladies and
gentlemen welcome
your September 2020
un momento
oh wait sorry Bob
we're about to bring Bob on
ah
un momento
Mis Amigos let's go back and here we go
ladies and gentlemen welcome
your September winner it's Bob Kirk
everyone
Bob Kurt
[Applause]
hey Joel what's good which way do I go
there we go there we go get right in the
middle there we want to see that pretty
face oh yeah yeah
[Music]
how are you doing Bob oh good good I'm
uh I'm I'm shocked and surprised wow
that was close that was ridiculous that
was really close that may have been our
closest [__] that may have been our most
votes yet either the show keeps getting
bigger and bigger which is exciting
that's cool yeah how did um
go ahead
Sandra and Sandy great job I have to say
that yeah terrific nice set good point
yes yes the humility I appreciate the
humility there Bob
yeah and it is good yeah everyone did
great it was it was a tight race for
sure but
To the victor
goes the OG it's Mr Bob Kirk a repeat
winner here gosh how many times have you
won now no I'm not sure you lost count
and that's not the age he's uh he really
is he's one a little bit of Alzheimer's
I think
but you win also because you keep
submitting as well you know you're like
putting in the work and you're putting
in the Reps so that's a that's a big
part of it as well
yeah I uh every month I I submit you
know it's a good I think like you said
it earlier it's a great exercise to
write and come up with stuff and
generally I write more than you know the
90 seconds so it's almost like possibly
end up with a five minute set you know
yeah on the themes you know so I try to
flush them out a little bit more you
know and
hopefully take it to the stage so how
did um how did this set come to be and
people in the live chat uh were
commenting your energy as well on this
one how do you how do you um how do you
bring it with so much energy I don't
know I just I've always been
had energy like I'm you know my
background's mostly improv and sketch
right so with the Improv you gotta
always bring it so I try to you know
push that towards the the comedy a bit
and doing some ACT outs try to be a
little more animated I mean because
you're in this little square box really
you know when you think about it with
the the phone camera you know so
um I try to change it up if I can you
know
for sure you know do you have any
rituals or anything that get you hyped
up even if you don't feel feel hyped
but you know what I probably I probably
did that set about 15 times before I got
it
right you know so many takes right it's
like holy you know like stumbled the
words or something wasn't right or it
goes too long you know all all those
factors you know just I think the more I
do it you know the the the better it
gets like usually I end up with the near
the end the better better takes you know
but gotcha yeah and trying to do it a
little bit ahead of time I think is is
good you know and I I um I should
actually you know give a shout out to to
uh the Riff room you know uh uh well you
for what you do for sure you know and
everybody I mean look at you you kept it
going so long for us you know it's great
I know you're busy with your own career
and and gigs and all that so it's nice
that you still can maintain and and and
do it for sure I love it I love it right
yeah for Bobby for I mean she puts the
word in there every day and Evelyn memes
you know I mean it's a it's a lot of uh
effort on a lot of people's parts so I
think you're doing great you know yeah I
don't want to make it sound like you
have a whole uh staff you don't I hope
to one day I mean gosh the goal is to be
like employing comedians one day you
know but it's all uh it's all one bite
at a time so all everyone that
volunteers whether it is like posting
things or even just answering questions
in the group and whatnot like I
appreciate all of it because I know
everyone has lives and everyone has
their own things to deal with so the
fact people even take the extra time to
compete in this contest or like you said
even to just engage in the Facebook
group and things like it all it all
makes my heart smile it really does yeah
well I think it's a great exercise you
know to to do it and come up with
material that you know you're
challenging yourself you know for sure
for sure I look at it like that but I
also look at it it's good to challenge
yourself you know you're always learning
and have to
you know I don't think it can ever be
satisfied with
your set you got to always keep creating
I think you know
you know changing it and trying to make
it better better or as best as you can
you know so I think it's a real
challenge but yeah again shout out to
you you guys and I have to say shout out
to Joan and Jack I mean Jones runs her
her room every Monday at 6 00 p.m you
know and I'm in there I Know Jack is in
there a lot there's other people that
come in and go out and come in you know
and then Chris grulla you know for
running the Riff room it's it's a great
asset you know Monday to Friday at three
o'clock so uh yeah Chris Dino Lorna
Jones in that too Emma Remy sorry Andy
when he gets around and not on the road
and Rory Quinton Bernice
Sarah and Juan Carlos I hope I got
everybody and didn't move on with my
development well I'll be left without
the Christmas list
so for for this set here uh Bob what
what's your favorite joke that you have
oh God I don't know I you know it was to
me this set was fun to write because it
just you know you throw back to school
right like so thinking of all the things
that that I did in school like I was
hyperactive as a kid I I had glasses but
they didn't know I couldn't see the
board so I'm running around and I was
deaf in my left ear for until grade
three so you know I had all these uh
attributes gone for me right so I was
just a Nutty kid you know I I have to
say that I'm not surprised
it was a Grade Three teacher Mrs Johnson
I know her I remember her name because I
was so hyperactive that she put me in a
Grade Three play that uh what was it
Cinderella oh wow I got to play the The
Prince and be in Tights so that was
embarrassing
I think her idea was you're so hyper
you're gonna put you inside and then my
mom and dad got me involved in sports so
I was like just uh you know on the go
constantly right but but and I'm not
kidding like you know they had corporal
punishment in our day like getting the
scrap and I see teachers you know knock
you around there's a one teacher he
looked like a marine he had a short
brush cut he had one kid up over the
lockers pounding him against the wall
right and when one lady and and uh I
think it was great five she was doing
you know those spelling bees when they
do those spelling bees she Billy Pinto I
remember his name
you had some word wrong and she grabbed
his head where am I okay and just banged
it against the board you know you every
letter every oh my gosh Bob was a School
of Hard Knocks good
yeah now you can't even raise your voice
I don't know it's it's different but so
to me it was fun writing this you know
and brought back a lot of memories for
sure yeah yeah that's what I try to do
with themes to make them like broad
enough to where but also specific enough
to where you can draw personal
experiences based on like the theme you
know and kind of make it what you want
it to be
yeah I mean and then you know you
embellish a bit but but uh yeah I
remember getting the scrap and grabbing
the grabbing the strap from the
principal she was an older lady probably
I don't know she looked like she was
next to death or in her 60s
but then she went and got that that
teacher the guy the marine and uh he
finished off the job
nice oh and Jerry asked how did how did
Bob get all those jokes crammed in there
in less than two weeks I thought I had a
lot of punch lines at 15. Bob had 15 in
the first 25 seconds well I don't know I
just you know I know it's different like
doing it outside or in your garage or
whatever like it's not like I'm waiting
for the laugh it's just go go right I
know it's different when you're in a
club and the audience you gotta kind of
wait for a reaction but I think with me
I figured I'd just uh boom put it put it
out there and I know you should you know
take your time a bit and
I don't know pause for the laugh but I
think it's different doing it live and
then doing it for the video yeah it's a
different timing for sure yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you do have a lot of
punch lines in there a lot of people
were commenting on that but yeah how
yeah what what's your favorite punch
line and then yeah how did you cram so
many in there
I don't know I I like to I like the
first one that you know I had the beard
you know Fuller beard than mostly
teachers and yes we're just women
uh and I like the toe tag one you know
like uh you didn't need a note you need
a toe tag to get out of clothes I missed
that one I heard I caught that punchline
while we're watching it live that was
that was there's so many jokes that you
it's tough to keep up with all of them
and that one slipped by me when my wife
and I were watching it that's that was
so funny yeah you know that that's one
of my favorite ones for sure
you keep writing I I think that was my
seventh draft on that you know
uh you know a lot of run out you know
and just sort of free associate and then
hone it hone it own it and you know
synthesize it down to the 90 seconds
right yeah exactly well what what what
advice you seem to have a good system in
Rhythm here do you have any advice for
anyone who like wants to get more
consistent at writing or level up their
writing like you know like you you okay
so there's education like doing your
course and and Jerry corley's got a lot
of Great Courses taking some of his you
know and and I think
Jerry's really good I mean very good at
you know he's been on the show several
times too we've done a lot of different
podcasts with them too yeah I know and
he's just a a wealth of uh knowledge and
he really puts it out there and he
enjoys it you know yeah I do it's like
Monday Monday a la carte stuff and
different courses that he offers so I
think that's helped I think that's one
thing you know talk about the school
theme it's like you always you know
always self-educate you know educate
yourself you know there's nothing wrong
with that because every time I do it I
learn something new or yeah better that
you forgot about and say oh you know
like all these different structures that
he talks about learn but then put it
into practice I think a lot of times
people will just consume consume consume
and not actually like do so I think
there's got to be a balance between
consuming and learning but then also the
doing part right right for sure yeah and
uh yeah I I uh I I enjoy that I take a
lot from that so I I look at it as
that's one part of the whole as a whole
that you have to do is is continually
educate yourself whether it's books or
courses or you know yourself or Jerry uh
you know get just keep doing keep doing
that you know make it a part of your day
right and uh
um well I use a lot of the like I'll use
that uh what is it um uh
uh the free The Source you know yeah
that's a great website yeah yeah that
and the phrases one there's one on
phrases and and uh word hippo right and
and I'll use also the uh um I printed
them off so
um I print everything up look at me talk
about an old school and it's all paper
the planet thanks you yeah yeah
I'm planting trees
well my daughter was a tree planter so
that's good so I can clean them she
plants them yeah that cancels out yeah
yeah yeah what's the balance right
um geez I don't know what what I was
gonna say now no yeah I mean I was
asking for people wanting to write more
but you gave good tips there learning
but then also doing yeah yeah and and
using those Freight like with the theme
and then I'll go to the Google machine
and and use that right like punch in you
know school and see what comes up for
the themes for that you know
you know so technology and I were always
I'm always trying to learn like now I'm
trying to get into editing and that's
you know it's like okay well learn how
to write jokes and take some courses and
try and practice and and do and now I
gotta learn to edit because I've just
started I haven't put it I haven't
posted anything yet like a YouTube
channel so
um I'm gonna do that but I do have tick
tock tick tock I was gonna say up here
on Tick Tock yeah I got I got one of my
videos got banned you know
my what my my twerking video
I was I was what do you call a Stitcher
you put side by side you know Miley
Cyrus in me and we're twerking and it
got community standards or something
what
I think that's hilarious that is
hilarious for sure so I'm doing Tick
Tock and then Facebook and Instagram so
so I'm slowly trying to get into all
that stuff you know but that's a whole
that's another learning curve in itself
and then like I said the editing right I
gotta learn how to do that stuff you
know it's like you got to be a one-man
production show marketing selling yeah
writing perform all of that you know I
don't know how I don't know how Comics
do it you know I'm I'm an old head now
Bob you know been this game 12 years and
I don't know how you kids
perform and film it and then post it and
I mean like it's it's I mean I I have to
do that now but I just can't imagine
starting out
trying not to bomb at this coffee shop
while also filming it to then try to
post it on Tick Tock like is there's so
many moving parts now
I know you always have to do it hey you
know what I don't have much time I mean
I'm getting up there so who knows how
much time I got left on this well you're
making the most of it Bob and I'm a fan
and I'm telling you every time like my
my wife and I love watching these and
every time you pop on it pull up Kirk
every like it just it just makes it just
makes us smile man so I just love to see
that you're doing it every month and
that you're doing more and more and more
and more you know because that's what
this game is all about and engaging in
the community you know I think it's
another big part of it is that you're so
part of the hot breadth of Earth and
taking advantage of everything out there
in it that um it's really showing it's
it's good and and I got some good news
for Toronto here for uh
um I think back in 21 like before the
pandemic I was in the uh the guy uh vong
show did produced uh
six seasons of Fresh so it was basically
fresh new communities like fresh faces
right yeah that's the one where we went
and liked the video right yeah anyway
that was I was on the first season I
came in first for that year so I think
what he's doing is taking the first the
people that came in uh first and second
and then doing your best of fresh so
that's coming up at the end of the month
October 29th at the uh oh God what's the
name of the theater big fancy theater
like a a restored they they renovated
this uh this theater and uh it's it's
pretty pretty good I'm looking forward
to it and he's going to do uh he's doing
uh what do you call it uh a stream like
eight camera shoot so wow and then he's
shooting he's shooting this yeah October
29th best of fresh at uh Paradise
Theater on Blue Street oh that's so cool
will anyone in the Toronto area
definitely go support that yeah I think
tickets are coming up for sale in the
next week or so
um it's a 300 seat theater so uh
how cool that'd be wild
yeah yeah yeah so and I'm doing other
little clubs you know I haven't been out
as much as I should be you know but uh
anyway I'm trying I'm trying it's it's
could over should there's no pressure to
have to need or feel to do anything you
you're doing a lot everyone you know we
all can beat ourselves up of could do
more but just grateful for what you are
doing you're doing a lot there buddy
I'm trying to keep it you know I I truly
do enjoy the writing though I think I
enjoy that the most you know but uh
anyway
I love that well where can people follow
you and um check out all the amazing
things you're doing
yeah that's my twerking on Tick Tock you
report your twerk top yeah yeah yeah
sorry you should have seen it earlier
that's all
the special on its own
uh well I I am on Facebook you know you
know Bob Kirk or Bob with 1-0 uh
Instagram bobkirk dot comedy uh Tick
Tock and I'm gonna start a YouTube Bob
Kirk comedy and and I what I want to do
is post one of the first things I could
I think I got at least 10 of these 90
second bits you know yeah
put those on on uh on YouTube and uh
because they're on Tick Tock but uh
um the other thing as I've created I've
been writing writing quite a bit uh and
I've been working on I'm doing this uh
Ned the empty nester a character piece
and all based on what is it I haven't
posted any yet but just I don't know if
you guys can see this a thousand to the
other way a thousand and one ways to be
romantic yeah yeah and it says up here a
book worth worth memorizing nice
so I I gave Myrtle my girlfriend I gave
her gardening tools and uh she wasn't
that impressed with the garbage
she got me this book and she said uh you
know you get you you memorize a thousand
and one ways and and be more romantic so
uh I'm working on I'm on page four yeah
it's a big book yeah
and my memory is not that great so it's
gonna take
so what I'm doing is I'm taking the
things in the book and then doing a like
trying to do a joke so it's like a setup
a straight set of that boom so so that
that's what I've been working on quite a
bit so I'm hoping to do what do you call
it not not a channel but uh
what's it you know when you put
different like if I do the 90 seconds
with Bob and then this you know uh Ned
the empty nester yeah like a series yeah
like you know in in the different
categories on that YouTube like within
the same channel so oh yeah you're gonna
kill that yeah that's awesome well I
will link to um I'll link to your social
media in the uh the description of this
episode as well and I mean as always Bob
it's always it's always a pleasure my
friend is there is there anything else
you want the world to know before we
I just
it's such a it's such a good group and
and and uh you know on and and she said
Emery too because he's doing the the
night you know like I always yep right
tin after dark yeah always uh tell
everybody you know about the word of the
day you know Bobby 10 at 10 o'clock and
ten at night so you can write twice in
one day and you know sort of gives you a
you know kicks you off anyway with the
word of the day exactly yeah and that I
will link to that that's in our um
riding room Facebook group so I'll be
sure to link to that as well because
there's a lot of we're coming up on 5
000 comics in that group so that's very
exciting yeah that's great and then all
your interviews that you've done over
the time and you're doing the shorts now
and everything so that's yeah yeah we're
going for it Bob yeah going for it baby
pretty soon you'll have your own uh uh
streaming Network
I'm excited one bite at a time we're
doing one bite at a time but we
appreciate you so much there Bob you've
been in it since the beginning my friend
so it's cool to see you us all growing
together that's the whole goal you know
yeah just keep writing keep at it keep
practicing and writing and yeah get up
here and perform that's that's a that's
the only thing I can say I know you say
it everybody says it all the time anyway
but it's actually doing it I mean you
know it's like people are like how do I
lose weight I was like well you like
diet and exercise but they're like but
really how do I do it it's like you kind
of write and perform a lot that's really
it um
but uh yeah it's part of it oh for sure
yeah anyway I hope I didn't leave
anybody out God Jesus
you did great Bob and uh congratulations
again my friend it is always it is
always a pleasure my friend thanks and
thanks everybody out there in the hot
weather
boating or showing support that it's all
great absolutely well you have a good
day out there Bob I I am I'm I'm not
it's funny I'm going to the island in
Toronto here though my friend I'm
meeting with all teachers
for teachers and one of them was our
history teacher in high school he's 82
years old what yeah and he still he's a
principal though what on the theme of
school day that is incredible yeah yeah
who invited me out there he just retired
this year so uh yeah so that'll be fun
make the most of those moments you don't
you never know how many of those you're
gonna get you know just when you get to
spend time with people it's making the
most of it because you just never know I
know for sure so it should be a lot of
fun yeah it will be safe travels to that
I'm gonna bring my old report cards and
get him to remark
the office
have a do-over please oh
I love it oh well enjoy that I'm uh I'm
gonna be doing some gardening today so
you know how that goes but uh I feel
like that's been the theme since we
started this during the pandemic but
we're still working on it it's still
it's still going you need just to get a
bobcat that's that's what yeah
exactly
well Bob it's always a pleasure my
friend so um I appreciate you so much
and congratulations dude well deserved
okay and thanks thanks for having me
thanks everybody
rest of the Sunday yeah enjoy congrats
Bob
thank you bye bye bye-bye all right way
to go Bob way to go
[Applause]
congrats to Bob oh my gosh that was so
cool
and like I said at the beginning I know
we went a little bit over today and I'm
oh my gosh uh we did start a few minutes
late but that's on me there but really
quick
I do want to announce the theme
for uh October so y'all can get on that
as well so let me do the drum roll
and remember
you
if you want to compete in next month's
contest all you got to do is join our
comedy writing master class at
hopbreathmedia.com
but the theme
for October
the season is changing so the theme is
changed my friends the theme is changed
I will also post this in the Facebook
group as well
but my friends you now have two weeks
to write
a 90-second set
based on the topic of change and this
can be done whatever way you like it can
be life changes physical changes
spiritual changes changes in money it
could be whatever you want it to be but
it's all about change what has changed I
think just I won't even tell you just
use it the way you like but I think this
is another good theme of you can start
to find a lot of
personal experiences based on this theme
and that's the whole goal is to write
personal material that you can then do
on stage that's the whole goal so the
theme of this month is change my friends
so go forth
and you now have two weeks my friends
have fun with it you know join the Riff
room join the writing rooms and um write
together you know get feedback and
whatnot but congrats to Bob again it's
always fun
and um
that's it we're Landing This Plane my
friend
I love you all so much though I really
do appreciate you all for hanging out
and um you can check out Bob's podcast
tomorrow right on the podcast but until
then my friends I love you all so much
y'all have a good
safe travels have fun whatever you're
doing
and we'll see on the other side my
friends
bye
[Music]
thank you